[Music]
hey there guys so this is uh good Lord I
think part four of uh po flowers uh last
week we learned how to do split Time
same direction flowers in insin and this
week we're going to talk about how to do
uh split time opposites in spin flow
um which thankfully I think at least are
a little bit easier than split Time same
direction at least if you've done the
work for split Time same direction I
think split opposites winds up feeling
that much easier so uh let's go ahead
and dive in uh the place to start is get
down a good split time opposites uh
pattern for yourself directly in front
of you in butterfly right um split
opposites feels very much like double
Dutch jump roping yeah um I also tend to
kind of think of it as like you're
closing a little Pac-Man head on either
side of you every time you do it so a
mouth there mouth there kind of thing
it's kind of a silly uh visualization
but it works for me you know the
challenge once you've gotten here is
you're going to get this as low as you
can and you're going to pick one hand I
don't care which one but that hand is
going to rise up your Center Line and
you're going to try and keep those two
points split opposites now you'll
notice when I get that hand up it
results in a timing where it looks like
the poads are coming together in the
middle this is in start contrast to when
you're doing same time opposites in
which case they don't come together in
the middle but if you put your hands
together they come together at the top
and bottom right so split opposites they
do not come together at the top and
bottom but if you separate them they do
appear to come together almost like
they're kissing in the middle
right
cool
so almost everybody I know that tries
this has some problems with this at
first what are some ways that uh you can
use to get into this position well um
one way is you can try and raise that
hand up your Center Line and uh same
trick we use with split Time same
direction kind of tilt your body over
and check yourself such that you're
making it look like it's in same time
opposite to
you and then when you return to Vertical
you should be able to hold on to it for
one or two reps before it falls apart uh
another method I'm really fond of is
visualizing that you've got a pair of
rubber bands that are connected to your
wrists such that if you try and open
them it'll pull your wrist right back
together again yeah pull it open they
pull back together now grit um they're
never going to pull completely back
together but what that visualization
does for you is you imagine pull pull
pull back pull back pull back and what
that actually cues your hands into is
the fact that they're working in
opposite timing in order to maintain
this kind of relationship right so I'm
and this is a very exaggerated version
of it but I'm always pulling my hands
away from each other and pulling them
back together at the same time they're
not moving in parallel they're always
moving either towards each other or away
from each
other and that'll help you find that
timing
yeah beware about length here is very
easy to get
Tangles okay so you bring your hands
back together and now you practice
getting the other hand up and all the
same tricks still
apply can look at it from the side
visualize that rubber
band what have you now once you got both
of these it's time to start building up
your flowers in which case what you're
going to try and do is um go from a
place where one hand is up and one hand
is down and slide them past each other
such that you switch which hand is on
top yeah and you want to go with the
direction of the PO so um for
example the way I'm spinning right now
my right hand is spinning related to me
counterclockwise my left hand is
spinning clockwise so when my R right
hand is on top uh I'm going to bring
both my hands to the left and when my
left hand is on top I'm going to bring
both my hands to the right yeah
you can even make this simpler for
yourself when you first start out where
you'll just get in one uh pedal with say
your left hand on top and come back
around to left hand on top left hand on
top left hand on top then work your way
to doing both left hand then right hand
then left hand then right hand then left
hand then right hand and each time you
want to do that quick little check and
make sure that the PO heads are almost
like kissing each other in the middle
right cool so once again you want to
practice this such that you can do it 10
times without messing it up and then the
uh question becomes how do you get the
side positions going and here you have
uh a choice of a couple different
options just like we did with uh same
time same direction you can either take
this from uh a buz saww kind of place
like so or you can have um you can just
maintain the feeling that uh the poy are
always further away from your body than
the native arm is right so uh in either
case
what what you're really looking for is
when your hands are out to the side
you're almost doing like a little doggy
paddle um it's it's the exact same
motion as this kind of rubber band idea
that you're pulling them apart and
they're getting pulled back together uh
except done on a smaller scale and you
know since they're going past each
other's positions of course uh you can't
really use the rubber band metaphor
anymore but you know if you do
imagine that kind of dog paddle motion
that'll help you get the timing down
here and once again you start off on one
side and please please please check
yourself in a mirror as you're doing
this I I I I cannot overstate the
importance of working with mirrors when
you're learning any kind of split uh
split time
movement go from one side to the other
and once again get down that little kind
of dog paddle motion that'll help you
get your
timing and once you're pretty
comfortable with the sides integrate in
the tops and
bottoms now I know I've made this one
seem relatively quick to learn and it's
it's definitely going to have uh it's
its learning curve to it but truly I
think that if you've gotten down split
Time same direction this is a flower
that comes together much much easier
than if you just uh started from nothing
so yeah that's split time opposites and
uh next week I will be back with some
information on how you can begin working
on anti-spin flowers we've all done uh
in spin so far the past few weeks so
thank you guys very much for watching
and I will see you next Friday peace